Welcome to toxic.
I'm Jennifer van Fossen.
Today we are so lucky to have a group of actors and actresses with us from Tali.
Please join me on stage.
We have Charlene,
Farron,
Mackenzie Davis,
Ron Livingston and director Jason Reitman.
We are so glad to have you all here with us today.
Thank you for joining us.
We really are.
Well,
I saw the film last week with my husband and Gosh,
there were so many things that I could relate to being a parent,
being a mom.
And the one thing that struck me in particular is there's this one scene,
Charlene,
is where your character Barlow is pulling into the parking lot and trying to act
like everything is great and okay.
And she's struggling with our kids and,
and she,
she walks in I think is to the principal and says,
ah,
it's just such a blessing.
Yeah.
And this really is for all of you,
but I'd love to start off just by tell.
Tell us about the importance of that authenticity and the characters that you
have in this film.
Um,
I mean,
I guess I don't want to speak for all of us,
but I will,
I must,
I think,
I mean,
we definitely all discuss just how raw and honest this was,
this portrayal of parenthood.
That is definitely not something that I've ever read in a script.
And in my,
you know,
over 20 years of doing this,
I've might have partaken in that false portray motherhood on a film.
I think there was something about this that was just so,
and maybe it's also different now that I have kids.
I can't imagine making this film.
And before I had kids,
because there was so much of this that I,
I could just feel inside my own bones.
Um,
and through all the,
the horror of the truth of what it takes to be a parent,
there's this utter beauty,
um,
that comes with it.
And I think,
I think that's would definitely draw me to it.
I mean,
Jason wasn't really negative part of deciding to do this film,
but the story really.
Yeah.
You know,
here's one you oh yeah,
it was,
yeah,
it was like the story's good enough that I can deal with Jason again.
Yeah.
So,
so brave.
I nobody knows how brave I am.
Hmm.
To,
to that point of dealing with Jason Again,
this is your sort of your third film and what some have said is even sort of a
trilogy,
Jason With Juno and young adult,
what you did with Charlie's and it's like Lord of the rings.
Just like that.
Yeah.
What's,
what's important to you about these three films in the sequence of them
together?
I mean,
uh,
you know,
when I met Diablo over a decade ago now,
I don't think I could have ever guessed that we were starting this trajectory
with each other,
that we're somehow we were going to be in a kind of storytelling marriage.
And,
uh,
and now of course I just hope it continues for the rest of our lives and that we
keep on making movies like this.
Um,
I remember your anniversary cause that's a big part of it.
Oh fuck.
I blew it already.
I remember the first time we met,
we met at this place called the father's daughter,
uh,
in over on Fairfax,
near the grove enabled bar in there.
And shorter to dirty Martini.
I ordered a diet coke and it was just very on par for our relationship going
forward.
Um,
but you know,
Juno was a movie about growing up too fast and young adult was a movie about,
uh,
growing up a little too slow.
And this is a movie about that moment when you realize that you have to grow up
and you have to turn a chapter on your life and create room so that your child
can occupy the space that you were occupying.
Yeah.
And tell us a little bit more about,
you know,
what attracts you to this and to Diablo is writing.
Uh,
you know,
um,
it's funny,
you know,
surely Diablo and I are all around the same age and although we,
we came from different places,
uh,
there's some sort of connective tissue that when Diablo right to script the,
she's articulating things that we've all been feeling.
Um,
and,
and this is something that Diablo does really well.
She writes about an idea that we can all relate to,
which is not knowing where you're supposed to be in the arc of your life.
Uh,
I think we all often have this feeling like,
am I behind?
Am I ahead?
Am I doing this at the right time?
What was I supposed to do by now at this age?
Uh,
whether it's work with family,
uh,
you know,
you have you bought a house yet,
have you done this or that?
And so much for writing is about that.
And for whatever reason,
I think it connects all of us.
Yeah.
So to that point,
I'd love to speak to the dynamic between the two characters of Marlow and of
Tele Mckenzie,
which she play and the dynamics that you explore.
And there's relationships between women,
right?
There's,
there's episodes of judgment or younger self versus older self kind of feeling.
So tell me about the dynamic between these two women.
Um,
I mean it was an interesting role to play because of,
um,
the,
uh,
space that a documented in somebody else's life.
And trying to find out how you can be your own sort of shoulder to cry on and
support system without becoming like a really malevolent force in that person's
life.
Um,
I dunno,
I thought it was,
I mean when I think we'll just reiterate the same things over and over it,
but just a really honest approach to how lovely and Shitty it can be to be
female.
And I haven't had kids,
but I have been a woman my whole life.
And um,
there were so many things that it felt like Diablo was telling secrets from my
own life and you were like,
how do you know about it?
Um,
and yeah,
I just thought it was like a lovely female friendship that was really honest and
not,
um,
you know,
sugary sweet.
But,
um,
do you want to say anything?
I mean,
having been the younger one in the relationship?
No,
you said it so beautifully.
I totally agree with you.
I mean,
I think Diablo,
he doesn't know how to not write honestly.
And I think she loves that space where we all live.
Whether you're a woman or a man that's maybe not so pretty.
And I know for myself,
I'm very much,
I'm fascinated by that space.
And so to have a writer and a filmmaker who really wants to go and explore that
space,
it's really,
it's having to get a job like that were,
you know,
all of us get,
we get to live in the skin of real people who are going through maybe not so
nice things and maybe are not behaving and the best possible ways that they
could in those moments in the bed.
But it's,
but it's human and it's exploring that human condition.
And I love that
one.
Another moment I remember from the film is there's an episode in a coffee shop
where you are clearly very,
very pregnant.
Yeah.
And you're ordering a DECAF and yeah.
How dare I facing all this judgment from this woman who's giving you sort of
dirty looks and yeah.
Can you talk about that judgmental part that you sort of explore there,
that women do face pretty constantly in society?
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I think that we definitely live in a world where we're just so hard,
especially on parents because all of a sudden they're carrying this other little
human and I feel like the world almost feels like they can step in and have a
judgment because it's not really you.
It's that little person that they don't even know that's living inside of you.
And I definitely have been with,
I didn't have pregnancies myself,
but just,
you know,
with my adopted kids,
like I remember a mom pulling me aside and she was like,
you should not be using formula and I can like hook you up with some real breast
milk.
And it was just like,
ah,
and my kids are fine as of right now.
They're still good.
They're doing okay from the formula.
Um,
so I'd love to go a little bit deeper on that because the last movie that I saw
you in was atomic blonde,
right?
Very different type of a female little later.
Yeah.
It was a real super like kick ass by maybe.
And,
and you have a production company,
Denver and Delilah that was written up in variety not long ago for really
backing those powerful female centric stories.
So can you talk a little bit about how you pick your roles and how your company
decides on its projects?
Yeah,
we,
um,
we have a,
a cool little thing going on with Denver and Delilah.
We,
we're definitely fortunate enough to be in a place where,
um,
we do have a little bit more of a luxury where we can greenlight things that
might not get greenlit.
Um,
you know,
a film like atomic blonde,
uh,
very easily could've,
you know,
been a male driven film.
Um,
and to be able to have a little bit of that,
to be in that position where you can actually take a film like that and,
and get a studio like universal to back it,
that's a really nice place to be in an I,
I don't ever take that for granted.
You know,
we're also trying to,
we do a lot of television and,
and,
and film.
And so we're really trying to,
not just with female stories but really paying attention to um,
you know,
bringing women into the positions.
They're just very strong and right now.
And so we have a lot of projects that are maybe not directed by females,
but they're all female producers and uh,
and,
and so I think being in that position where you can kind of put your foot down
and you know,
I was just on a film that we produced and I walked on and our sound department
didn't have one woman on it and we had a bunch of female actresses on it.
And I was like,
guys,
what?
No,
like we need a lady here to be dealing with the bra strap.
Like,
um,
it's just a nice place to be in an,
and for me as an actor,
it's not necessarily always so that I can star in it.
It's nice that I can kind of take ownership and and guide a little bit of the
stuff that I do want to explore that you do get tired of kind of waiting around
for a filmmaker or a writer to come around and hand you something like that so
you can kind of step in and develop things that you're interested in.
And I love that and I liked that it can,
that I can be as diverse as I want to be.
And that I think is one of the hardest things or was for me in my career.
You,
you know,
you have gardeners,
some success and some genre and then that's all everybody wants you to do.
And having a production company gets me to do different things and kind of not
regurgitate the same thing over and over and over.
Yeah,
that's a,
that seeking of diversity and creativity and thought and female centric is
something we really value at and I do on my team as well,
so thank you.
Oh,
cool.
Ron?
Yes.
You're from Iowa.
And this is personally important to me because my husband's in the audience and
he's from Iowa as well.
So shout out to the Hawkeyes
you are,
you have two daughters.
So tell us from a,
from a male perspective,
so what's important to you about this title and Jason,
I know you have a daughter as well,
I believe.
Yeah.
So I'd love to hear from you all about what's important to you about the female
empowerment from your perspective too.
And drew is Marla's as Marla's husband and the title.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
cause I'm raising two girls to enter into the world.
I like the world to be a,
a welcoming and uh,
you a nice place for them to be and I want them to be valued and I want them to
be empowered and want them to feel strong.
Um,
they're pretty strong right now,
so I feel really good about it.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and then the,
the rest of this stuff,
I guess we'll,
I guess we'll get to,
um,
I,
what I like about this,
the,
the way that this setup is,
is any talked about the authenticity is I feel like there's a,
uh,
there's a sort of a husband,
a mold of like what husbands do,
uh,
and the,
and the child rearing area.
Uh,
and in real life the bar is a lot lower than what you see in the movies and the
movies.
It's like we kind of give them a lot of the benefit of the doubt and credit and
uh,
you know,
so in this,
this character,
it's really,
he's contributing closer to what a husband's generally actually contribute and
think they're doing a great job.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
you know,
I don't know how that relates to the,
uh,
female empowerment,
element overall.
But,
uh,
you know,
it's a,
it's a wife part.
I'm playing on wife part is what they would call it.
And it's Kinda great that it's flipped around.
Um,
cause I know my wife has played a lot of wife parts and uh,
and made some wonderful things out of them.
So,
uh,
that was a really good challenge of like,
okay,
I gotta take this guy who's a,
uh,
in a,
in a supportive functioning Grohl and figure out like,
well how can we make it real?
Great.
Anything you would add there,
Jason?
I mean,
the funny thing is that a,
that I'd really like to make a movie for my daughter,
but I,
I've made eight movies so far and she hasn't seen any of them because they're
all rated r or about teen pregnancy.
So I have a lot of conversations waiting for me.
Okay,
got it.
Um,
well another thing that I'd like to touch on with y'all as you've,
and you've mentioned a little bit of this Sharlay's,
you've both done sort of small screen and big screen work and,
and my role here at Google,
I worked quite a bit with the film studios,
uh,
and also the broadcaster.
So I think it's interesting what's going on between small and big screen these
days.
And also I think it's really important that these kinds of stories make it to
the big screen still.
And it's not just a world of sequels and blockbusters.
So I thought maybe y'all could talk a little bit.
Yes,
that's true.
That's true.
But with unique characters yet.
Um,
so I'd love to just talk about how do we,
how do we encourage and make sure that these types of stories are told on the
big screen as well.
I mean,
the best way to do is to make them,
that's I think the first,
the first step.
Um,
you know,
and it's,
thank God you're doing that.
Uh,
I don't really feel that there's that much of a difference.
the cameras the same size,
uh,
in any case,
but whether it's a big screen or a small screen,
that stuff all comes later.
I feel like when,
uh,
you know,
your problem maybe thinking about that,
but when,
when I show up to work,
it's,
you know,
I'm not thinking about the screen.
Um,
and I think people have a great relationship.
I feel like the difference and people have some pretty big screens in their
houses now too,
you know,
and there's gonna be a lot of people who watch this,
watch this on downloaded on their phone,
the pirate it or something.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
so yeah,
no,
I,
um,
to me I think it's a more of a thing of when the big screens still has that
place for like,
this is an event.
We're going to give this our evening,
we're going to get out of our house,
we're going to,
you know,
we're going to go sit down,
buy expensive popcorn and,
and we're locked into this.
We can't flip the channel.
If we don't like it,
we can walk out,
you know?
But that's a very dramatic thing.
Um,
so it's,
yeah,
it's nice that we're giving adult fare,
I think.
I guess if you're an adult,
so it's not so much about the screen,
then it's about the projects getting made and the story's being told,
regardless of,
I hope we hold onto the collective experience.
That's the important thing.
I think there's a lot of conversations about screens and sound and,
uh,
and that's all well and good.
It's nice,
although I find,
I go to the movies all the time and I think,
man,
why don't they turn this up?
A,
I wish they would play movies louder and theaters and,
uh,
and change the bulbs and the projectors more often.
But I'm also a nerd.
Um,
but,
uh,
but what I think is important is the collective experience
is you go to the movies
with a bunch of strangers and you're all laughing together.
Are Y'all crying together?
You're all being moved together,
you're all realizing something together.
And that is very rare experience.
I think that's an important experience.
Uh,
I mean,
he certainly has been throughout my childhood.
I love movies,
a trek to the movies.
It's many times a week as possible.
But,
uh,
and I,
and by the way,
I love and I watch a lot and I binge a lot as well.
I think it's a great,
it's a great form of entertainment.
What I'd hate to lose though is the collective experience.
That doesn't only happen for,
uh,
movies like Black Panther but also happens for tiny movies that can really
change minds and move us.
Cause it,
there's something different about watching a movie at home alone and having that
experience just moving,
but it's alone and having it as a community with people you don't know,
you all showed up at this theater from maybe all parts of the city.
You all come from different lives and now you're all laughing together.
And I think the thing that I fear losing the most is that,
that's a great point.
So if the audience wants to kind of get ready,
I think we're going to do a little bit of a Q and.
A if you guys want to get ready for that.
And uh,
I'm curious,
Jason,
like is there a movie that was like that for you?
Like,
can you think back?
Uh,
uh,
I mean,
in movie theater experience,
I mean there's a hundred,
but,
uh,
I remember lining up to see pulp fiction and a,
I was in high school and that was,
that was one of the great nights of my life.
I mean,
I think about that night,
the way that people think about,
you know,
uh,
lining up for some shows at CBGBs in the 70s or something like it just that,
that's a,
that was a life changer.
Yeah.
How about the rest of you?
Can you think of a title that was really mean?
I just,
I was sharing this with Jason.
Um,
and I think my friend is here who's a producer on this to best Kono and I went
to go see a shape of water and we're both kind of dead inside as people.
We have a lot of emotion and I started crying.
So uncontrollably I felt,
I was literally like,
Oh my God,
this is so embarrassing.
And then I just looked over and she was crying and I was like,
yeah,
I'm not a Weirdo,
but it's like Jason said,
like I could have never experienced that at home.
And um,
and it's nice to have that conversation after too,
right?
Like the,
the,
the credits start rolling and like you start talking about it collectively and
her,
something nice about that.
And I do think like,
sometimes people have experiences,
they watch films at home and they don't have the same experience.
And you do when you're in that theater with other people is something that
happens.
Maybe it's expensive popcorn,
I don't know.
But something definitely happens for me.
It did.
Yeah.
I'm not dead.
Turns out,
okay.
I saw us store star wars is a fifth grader and it kind of rocked my world.
Um,
not only just the,
you know,
the SPEC,
the goal and the way it just kind of exploded.
Uh,
you know,
there,
there wasn't anything like that before.
And then all of a sudden there was,
but I feel like that just the,
all the mythical
stuff,
um,
it's like a primer in eastern philosophy,
you know,
in like Tau Ism Zen and uh,
that has lasting effects.
You know,
I think it,
it's,
it's cheesy to say,
well,
I don't think it changed my life,
but yeah,
it had to have wars,
star wars changing my life,
you know,
I get it.
My local,
this is not like that at all.
My whole movie theater is this really old dingy place.
And I think it's where they shoot those like night vision examples where they do
screeners of scary movies and people are like popcorn.
And I saw it there,
this the one that just came out and I had to wait in line that wrapped around
the block and it was like a 30 minute wait and then it was just like 11 to 17
olds and we all watched it together and it was so,
it felt like religious where everybody likes screamed at the same time and then
you'd turn to the stranger and be like [inaudible].
It was so fun to be in that space again and it just reminds you like you don't
cause all you get at home.
It's sort of like hmm,
but not the full like Cathartic scream and communal energy.
This very movie when the person next to you was scared,
the energy transfer and,
and you'd do the like scream to laugh ratio is on your car and it's so fun and
weird.
Shall we open it up now?
Thank you all so much for coming.
I was able to watch the film earlier today.
And what I'd like to think that the magic of Diablo script was part of this.
I'm really curious for Mckinsey and Charlise.
Um,
it hasn't,
I don't want to spoiler alert,
but it has such an unusual twist at the end.
I was not expecting it and I just thought you two were so separate,
but then so connected.
How did you develop that?
Because that magic just wasn't in the script.
He slept with each other
and it was awkward at first,
but then it just like broke down this barrier right away.
It helped,
yeah.
Anything to know someone's body like that is especially that body.
There's a lot to explore there.
Um,
I,
I've been very lucky.
Uh,
Jason,
uh,
is
really,
really good at casting
obviously.
Uh,
no,
but seriously,
he's just so good at counseling.
I remember when we did young adult together,
he only brought up one name and it was Patton Oswald.
And I didn't know who Patton Oswald was.
So it was a little bit like,
Ooh,
who's this?
And then he showed me some stuff and it was like,
really?
And then we got on set and it was like,
ah,
God,
that's,
you just see something.
And so this time around,
it was the same thing.
The only name that was ever brought up was mackenzie.
And uh,
and there were,
I mean for me when I read the script there were,
because it was so intricate that does this relationship between us,
I definitely read it in that sense,
you know?
And so I was like,
cool,
it's going to be interesting.
Like what do you do with this?
And Mckenzie showed up and it was just so beautifully weird and odd and,
and pretty much from the moment that I met her,
I was just like this.
And so it was perfect for the film and then she ends up like,
she's a cool girl.
So it was nice to be on set with her and to share this experience with her.
Okay.
You're welcome.
Um,
yeah,
I feel like we did an like plan anything out too much.
And we just talked a bit about,
um,
I remember that breakfast that we had in that weird hotel and the Sutton hotel
where we just talked about like getting older in a really low yeah,
normal but way like,
I don't know,
we have the same body type and like what it's like to be used to the way your
body behaves for your whole life and then what happens when it starts behaving
in a different way and just simple things that can kind of bond you to someone
quite easily and make you,
I dunno,
there's like certain the sound,
so like something that Cosmopolitan magazine would say,
but there are something like certain like secrets of being female that can make
you feel very close to someone immediately.
Um,
without needing to,
to like,
you know,
map out a whole plan right away.
I think she's also one of the funniest people I've ever been around.
See.
And,
and so that's just so disarming.
And I think instantly we really connected on that.
I was just like,
every time I was around I was like,
cause I was not the funnest person on the shoot.
Um,
I kind of dealt with depression for the first time in my life and my body was
just not happy and my mind wasn't happy in my soul isn't happy.
And being around her was just real joy and I think we,
I definitely got close whether she liked it or not,
I got closer to her through that.
I was very happy when she,
Ron,
I was happy when you were there too.
Yeah.
I was happy when you were there too in a different way.
Um,
I love Roddy different though.
You don't know what it's like.
Ron is you,
by the way,
the nicest person you'll ever meet on the face of the earth.
Hands down.
Way Nicer than you know.
I'll just point out you,
you guys as best as foils.
Yes.
Go ahead,
you guys for being here.
I'm just curious,
was it hard to get this movie made given that it's a movie about motherhood,
being a new parent and multiple kids?
Is this a hard one to pitch or do you feel like there's an appetite for that
right now?
How much we're exploring motherhood and you're seeing it more in shows and
films.
I don't think,
uh,
they're traditionally not easy to get financing.
I don't think there,
uh,
I have not heard of any studio out there are saying,
you know what,
let's look for more real human drama,
a particularly female human drama that's um,
although you're right,
there's a lot more of that happening in television now.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
frankly,
you know,
a company called Bron studios up in Vancouver,
uh,
finance this film and they came in early and they came in strong.
They liked the script.
Uh,
they loved this cast,
uh,
clearly and,
and they back to film and they were kind of amazing start to finish.
Uh,
there was never any kind of a,
I'd never felt them trying to bend it into something that it wasn't a knee.
You know,
the people that were already big fans of Juno and young adult,
they got the tone of it going to what we wanted to do.
And,
and we got it made,
but I,
but I feel lucky about that.
I think we're very fortunate that we got to get this film made.
I think there's a lot of homes like that or trying to get made that are not
getting the financing if only we were at a company with a limitless amount of
funds that can invest into movies and tomorrow.
Yeah.
I would think they really cared about women.
They would start investing money into female driven independent film.
Huh.
Like that.
This,
my question goes to Jason because I'm an aspiring filmmaker and I,
I haven't got a chance to see the movie yet because it's release on May 4th.
May the force be with you,
by the way anyway.
So it's within the star wars universe.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Um,
it's a tall can crossover.
Yes.
Um,
I'm just really curious to know what you're directing processes like from or
from gained the script in your hands to development,
pre production,
post production to distribution.
How much was changed,
what was left,
and what was left out.
And,
um,
how were,
and through those changes,
how would you,
how did you define the characters from,
um,
from point a to point B and what was,
what was it like to pick out the color Palette for some photography and choosing
the appropriate lens is to tell the story?
I'm sorry.
Is there a lot?
I,
and they're all great questions.
It's a lot of them.
And I think if I were to answer all of that habit,
it would be,
it would take a while and I'm going to,
so,
uh,
and I'll,
I'll just say it
a couple of brief things.
Um,
uh,
the one,
what's unique about Diablo is that she is a pure writer and does not use index
cards or treatments.
She has an idea.
She called me,
uh,
at one point said I have this idea for a movie.
And she kind of told to me in two sentences and then six weeks later she had a
screenplay and it was a first draft,
but it was also our shooting draft.
And she just writes,
she sits down and starts with the first scene,
then the second scene,
and she lets the movie tell her what it's going to be.
And that's how she's written all our films.
And as another writer,
it's infuriating.
Uh,
I mean it took me seven years to write up in the air.
I don't know.
I don't know how she does it,
but her screenplays are very clear on the page.
And it's not to say that they're loaded with long paragraphs of detail.
They're very succinct.
They're very short,
the hundred page scripts,
but you can't help but read it and know what she's saying and what she's
referring to.
I feel like it's my job not to tell the actors how to do it.
It's to find people who I think have connective tissue with the characters on
the page.
Not that they're the same human being,
but there's something inside them that connects them to this character,
uh,
that I know is going to come to life.
Uh,
and then they bring it to life and I'm there to kind of help shape,
um,
and keep us with all in,
all within kind of one tonal world.
Uh,
but it's up to them and we don't rehearse,
you know,
we,
uh,
and it's something that you kind of brought that up.
We had one lunch,
uh,
before we went,
exam,
blocky.
I get to work with brilliant actors and I know on the day we're going to find it
and we're going to find it over a few takes or maybe a few more takes.
It's not going to be anything crazy.
And when that magic happens,
when,
when two actors,
when two really talented actors suddenly connect and have chemistry and the
lines come to life,
um,
there's nothing like it in the world.
I mean,
it's really an exciting thing to watch happen live and when it happens on what
the cameras to be on,
I don't want to be in rehearsal studio.
So that's a little bit of how the process was and it's certainly is how this
movie came together.
I think they have one more question and then we'll,
um,
so Charlise and Ron,
I think if you both,
this is really funny,
people who play characters with a lot of pain but really funny characters with a
lot of pain and um,
but you also do some sort of wackier characters and I,
and I'm sort of curious as artists and performers,
do you feel like that balance is important or do you lean one way or the other
that it's important to you to play characters who have some sort of non comedic
painful depth?
Oh,
that's a great question.
You want to take that or,
uh,
simultaneously,
you know what?
I want to assume my male privilege to go first.
I,
you know,
it's like the,
I think the pain is everybody has a pain and so if,
you know,
it's,
if it's useful to,
to bring it to the thing,
then that's great.
As far as the Wacky,
uh,
I just,
I think I'm just kind of Goofy,
you know,
there's like a,
there's an element of me this term that's kind of goofy and there was a while
there was a,
you know,
five years when I was trying to be a matinee idol and you know,
where the leather jacket and you're like,
I have on that.
And uh,
it was just really hard not to like make a face and,
uh,
because it,
there's something about it that if it strikes me as a little silly and,
and then that's the part that I like about it is like,
oh,
okay,
what's the,
what's the silly part?
Um,
but I,
I think it's all the same,
you know what I mean?
It's like he,
there's it people who are only in pain or only trying to be funny,
uh,
tend to be really infuriating people hang out with,
so you just throw it all together and see what,
what comes out of it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I agree with,
um,
with Ron,
I,
I don't believe that people are only one thing.
Um,
I think that,
I think that's also what makes this writing feels so great because it deals with
some very serious and,
um,
hard subject matter.
But through real people and I think real people,
I think we can all relate to that.
You know,
I've had shitloads of tragedy,
but nobody is just that one thing.
And I think a lot of people who have had a lot of tragedy in their life tend to
veer more towards the silly and the light light hearted ness of it in order to
survive.
I mean,
this is why I'm dead inside.
Uh,
didn't work for me.
But,
um,
I think there's a sense of humor about this that feels very real.
That's not just a joke for the sake of a joke or to be funny.
I think a lot of the humor of this film comes from very real places.
And I know for myself,
raising my kids,
it's,
it is a horror movie and a comedy with Will Ferrell and,
uh,
Star Wars,
it's everything.
It's literally every day.
I'm like,
I don't know what movie we're in today,
but can't wait to go on the ride.
See where we're at.
We're at lands.
I Dunno.
Does that,
is that?
That's great.
That's a bullshit.
I know.
I don't.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
Oh,
I don't know.
Thank you for this.
Do what he says.
Basically.
That's really what happens.
Me personally or just to know what Jason was.
Yeah.
We've been waiting for you to,
cause I'm waiting for you to tell me.
I get to respond.
Reminder,
may for everyone.
Please take your friends.
Go See Tali in theaters.
Thank you so much.
Right.